[Music]  i'm juan williams i've been at fox news  for 25 years so the thing about fox news  at the very beginning is that you had  the sense that you were in on the ground  floor and everybody there was scrappy  and so we were like just  people hanging in and fighting and  trying to one day hope that we could  overcome the big dogs you know what we  have to do something now this is a  tipping point part of the story for me  is that i'm the outsider people say well  why do you put up with that why are you  always in a fight in fox but in reality  you'd be surprised  the audience likes it the audience  appreciates that there is some drama  some real debate so many people who are  conservatives say to me  i don't agree with what you have to say  but i like you and i'm glad you're there  because then i know what the other  side's thinking